le monsieur le rapporteur général mes
chers collègues mesdames messieurs
nous continuons si vous le voulez bien
nos travaux de la matinée sur les crypto
actifs après la présentation que nous
avons eu à l'instant sur leur
fonctionnement de manière générale nous
poursuivons avec des enjeux posés par
ces actifs en termes de régulation mais
aussi d'innovation
8% des Français auraient déjà acheté des
crypto actifs c'est certes peu on peut
dire comme ça par rapport à la détention
de produits financiers traditionnels
mais c'est une proportion qui devient
significative pour des actifs assez
récents et encore difficilement
appréhender par les régulateurs nous
avons eu l'occasion d'aborder ce sujet
en commission avec l'examen du projet de
loi portant diverses dispositions
d'adaptation au droit de l'Union
européenne dans notre collègue Hervé
Moret était le rapporteur
c'est à son initiative que le Sénat
avait proposé d'imposer aux prestataires
de services sur actif numérique les psan
de disposer d'un agrément pour pouvoir
poursuivre leurs activités à l'issue de
la commission mixte paritaire un
enregistrement renforcé sera mis en
place au bénéfice de la protection des
épargnants
dès le mois d'octobre 2024 le règlement
européen sur les marchés des crypto
actifs dit règlement Mika devrait
prendre le relais avec un agrément
obligatoire ces évolutions s'inscrivent
évidemment dans le contexte de la
faillite de la société FTX une place
américaine ne marchait centralisée de
crypto actifs qui auraient perdu de 10 à
80 excusé pour la fourchette milliards
de dollars depuis les révélations se
sont multipliées sur sa gestion qu'à la
mitose voire frauduleuse et sur les
pertes encourues par les investisseurs
au-delà de la volatilité des crypto
actifs
en plus des faillites se sont également
4 milliards de dollars de crypto actifs
qui auraient été dérobé en 2022 dont
près de la moitié au profit de la Corée
du Nord à l'instant des régulateurs
européens les régulateurs américains se
font eux aussi de plus en plus critiques
sur les pratiques de certains acteurs
sont cités les risques de fraude
d'escroquerie les informations inexactes
ou trompeuses transmise aux
investisseurs la volatilité importante
de ses actifs les risques de gouvernance
ou encore les éventuels impacts sur les
acteurs financiers traditionnels
le tableau que l'on nous dresse des
crypto actifs peut donc apparaître un
peu sombre même si ces actifs sont aussi
porteurs d'innovation dans le domaine
financier et pas que pour nous éclairer
sur ces enjeux et sur ce paradoxe nous
avons donc le plaisir ce matin
d'accueillir madame Marianne barbal
Layani dans sa nouvelle fonction si je
puis dire de présidente de l'Autorité
des marchés financiers madame Faustine
fleuret présidente et directrice
générale de l'Association pour le
développement des actifs numériques
acronymes addane Monsieur Nicolas Louvet
président et directeur général de coin
house
monsieur Bertrand Perret secrétaire
général adjoint de l'Autorité de
contrôle prudentiel et de résolution
je vous rappelle à tous que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat
dans une audition de cette nature avec
quatre
intervenants nous souhaiterions que
chacun puisse intervenir à peu près dans
une vision d'une dizaine de minutes
introductives en sachant qu'évidemment
vous aurez un deuxième tour si je puis
dire légèrement plus court pour conclure
nos débats après les questions et je
vous indique tout de suite que pour la
réponse aux questions vous serez dans
l'ordre inverse de l'ordre de
présentation de manière à ce que chacun
puisse s'y préparer
voilà sans plus tarder je souhaite donc
la parole à Madame Marianne
pour qu'il nous rappelle évidemment le
rôle de l'Autorité des marchés
financiers dans la régulation des
prestataires de services sur actifs
numériques mais aussi dans le soutien
des innovations qui sous le temps de ses
actifs vous aviez ainsi déclaré madame
la Présidente que si Madoff ne veut pas
condamner la finance classique
FTX ne devait pas condamner la finance
digitale quel est donc dans ce contexte
le rôle et je vous cite en fait c'est
magnifique le rôle de l'AMF
madame
on verra monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur général Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
tout d'abord je dois dire je suis très
heureuse de retrouver la commission des
finances du Sénat j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer à l'occasion de l'audition
dans le cadre de ma nomination et je
garde un très bon souvenir de ces
échanges qui avait été à la fois très
pointue et très très intéressant pour
moi et qui m'avait effectivement permis
de prendre toute la mesure de ce que le
Sénat attend de la MF de sa présidente
et d'une autorité indépendante et sachez
que j'en ai gardé un souvenir très vif
je donc nous abordons aujourd'hui un
sujet qui est qui est évidemment au cœur
de l'actualité y compris législative
innovation et régulation dans le domaine
des crypto actifs
monsieur le Président vous avez employé
le terme de difficile je dirais que ou
difficilement pour les régulateurs donc
je dirais que en effet pour les
régulateurs c'est un sujet qui est un
peu difficile
parce que nous devons atteindre le bon
équilibre entre
l'accompagnement et le soutien à
l'innovation et la protection des
investisseurs qui est comme vous le
savez le cœur du métier de l'AMF sans
doute sa première priorité et en un mot
commençant notre boussole donc cela
nécessite de notre part de l'ouverture
d'esprit
la construction d'une expertise et j'y
reviendrai puisque effectivement nous
sommes face à un domaine nouveau une
relation forte mais saine avec ce que
l'on appelle entre guillemets
l'écosystème de l'innovation et je dois
dire que de ce point de vue
l'AMF je crois un bon positionnement
nous n'avons pas d'a priori négatif
contre l'innovation mais nous l'abordons
toujours comme je l'indiquais avec notre
boussole qui est la protection de
l'épargnant qui peut d'ailleurs je crois
qu'il faut le souligner et trouver des
avantages à la fois en termes de
facilité d'accès à des services
financiers
de faciliter d'usage sur les coûts et
l'accroissement de la concurrence l'AMF
est donc depuis plusieurs années
fortement engagée en faveur du
développement des fintech et de
l'innovation dans le secteur financier
j'évoque là un sujet qui est plus large
que celui des crypto actifs
effectivement c'est tout l'aspect
innovation puisque nous avons vu au
cours des dernières années les closion
d'innovation technologique majeures que
la MF a pleinement prise en compte à la
fois en termes des opportunités qu'elles
peuvent représenter pour l'industrie
financière pour les épargnants et pour
la place de Paris pour son attractivité
notamment mais également comme je
l'indique qui est dans le cadre de la
recherche de cet équilibre en termes de
risques qu'elles peuvent comporter pour
les mêmes acteurs notamment les
épargnants
la technologie blockchain tient une
place majeure dans ces innovations et la
MF a toujours accompagné le recours à
cette technologie depuis qu'elle est
apparue d'abord en rencontrant les
acteurs concernés je l'ai indiqué pour
le régulateur il y a un vrai enjeu de
développer sa compréhension et son
expertise dans ce domaine et nous avons
reçu pour ce faire près de 800 acteurs
ces cinq dernières années pour mieux
comprendre leurs projets et les enjeux
de développement nous sommes également
intervenus en publiant des guides des
avis des positions juridiques à
destination des acteurs et des
épargnants le cas échéant en émettant
des alertes d'ailleurs lorsqu'ils nous
semblait que les épargnants n'étaient
pas suffisamment conscient des risques
et en instruisant les dossiers qui nous
sont adressés au regard du cadre
français relatif aux actifs numériques
nous l'avons fait je le redis sans a
priori considérant qu'il fallait
encourager les sorts d'un écosystème
d'acteurs diversifié en construction
alors de quoi parle-t-on très rapidement
cette technologie blockchain recouvre de
nombreux cas d'usage et deux
principalement ceux qui concerne la
finance traditionnelle qu'il ne faut pas
oublier j'y reviendrai et celui qui vous
intéresse principalement aujourd'hui qui
est celui
d'actifs nouveau les crypto actifs alors
dans la finance traditionnelle je pense
que c'est un point qui ne faut pas
oublier parce que la technologie
blockchain est porteuse de
d'innovation très intéressante sur les
pour la gestion des titres financiers
classiques actions obligations qui
peuvent être alors on dit tokeniser je
sais pas si on dit en français je
tenisais
ce qu'il faudra que des spécialistes de
la terminologie se penchent sur ce sujet
on parle alors de sécurité
français et donc dans le cas de la
finance traditionnelle nous avons
rapidement
identifié qu'il pouvait y avoir un
impact majeur potentiellement positif
sur le traitement des titres financiers
classiques la blockchain permettant
potentiellement d'améliorer l'efficience
de la chaîne de transmission des titres
en en réduisant les cours en réduisant
aussi les délais et en la fiabilisant en
facilitant l'identification des
détenteurs des titres
ce secteur est couvert par des
réglementations européennes donc il faut
il fallait que celle-ci évolue pour
accueillir cette nouvelle technologie
sous la forme d'expérimentation de titre
financiers sur la blockchain notre
ambition était dès l'origine la mise en
place d'un régime dérogatoire pour
permettre l'échange de ces titres
financiers tokennisé sur des marchés
adaptés en apportant le même degré de
sécurité que sur un marché traditionnel
c'est désormais chose faite au niveau
européen avec le règlement européen qui
institue ce qu'on appelle le régime
pilote donc un régime pilote pour les
infrastructures de marché qui reposent
sur cette technologie blockchain
règlement européen qui a été publié en
juin 2022 et qui dès le 23 mars prochain
permettra d'agréer des projets vous
connaissez
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ce
texte puisque le projet de loi d'adultes
qui comporte aussi des éléments sur les
crypto actifs a permis d'adapter à notre
d'adapter notre droit à ces nouvelles
exigences européennes
l'AMF je le redis a soutenu la mise en
place de ce régime pilote qui est pour
ce que nous envoyons suffisamment ouvert
et susceptibles d'attirer des porteurs
de projets nouveaux et ambitions qui
pourraient favoriser l'innovation sur
les marchés financiers évidemment nous
ne pouvons pas anticiper l'avenir de ce
de ce régime et nous verrons si ce
régime est un succès si cette
expérimentation est satisfaisante et si
elle est comme nous pouvons l'espérer
porteuse à terme d'une véritable
révolution dans la structure des marchés
financiers elle permettra aux acteurs en
particulier les infrastructures de
marché de s'interroger sur de nouvelles
opportunités technologiques de
développement tout en maintenant nous y
serons évidemment attentifs des marchés
efficients transparents et protecteur
pour les épargnants
concernant maintenant les autres cas
d'usage de la blockchain beaucoup plus
connue que sont les crypto actifs je
rappelle très brièvement que la France
avec la loi pacte a posé dès 2019 les
bases d'une régulation et d'un
encadrement des activités sur actif
numérique qui ne sont pas des titres
financiers
à cet égard donc c'est c'est sur ce sur
ce texte là que repose la compétence de
l'AMF en tant régulateur compétences qui
est d'ailleurs sur certains aspects
partagés avec la CPR et mon voisin de
droite il reviendra très certainement
nous avions collectivement estimé à
l'époque un régime France
franco-français mise en place dans une
phase relativement précoce de l'essor
des activités sur crypto actif et
traitant d'opération sans ancrage
territoriale solide devait être souple
car il proposait un premier pas de ces
acteurs vers la régulation on peut dire
que c'était l'application d'une approche
type bac à sable en matière de
régulation
[Musique]
concerne les prestataires de services
sur actif numérique les psan a été un
volet plus porteur et j'y reviendrai en
termes quantitatif donc il comporte deux
étages un premier étage qui est très
minimal qui a un étage d'enregistrement
obligatoire dans lequel l'AMF va
vérifier l'honorabilité et la compétence
des dirigeants et des détenteurs du
contrôle du psan et du premier cercle
d'actionnaire et la CPR va contrôler le
dispositif de lutte contre le
blanchiment et le financement du
terrorisme à ce stade l'AMF a enregistré
62 San après avis conforme de la CPR ce
qui a permis de construire à la fois
d'accompagner la construction pardon
d'un écosystème français dynamique et de
développer l'expertise de du régulateur
dans ce secteur
ce régime d'enregistrement
nous avons déjà eu l'occasion d'en
parler dans le cas du projet de loi
d'adultes il est assez minimaliste
puisqu'il ne couvre il ne recouvre pas
d'exigences prudentielle ni de
protection des investisseurs ni de
prévention des conflits d'intérêts ou de
d'exigence en matière de cybersécurité
tous éléments qui font l'objet du
deuxième étage du régime français qui
est l'étage dit de l'agrément alors
l'agrément psane est optionnel
l'enregistrement étant obligatoire pour
ceux qui veulent intervenir sur le
marché français je le rappelle donc
l'agrément psan qui est lui opsonait
optionnel pardon est beaucoup plus
exigeant il apporte notamment une
dimension de protection des
investisseurs qui est inspiré de la
finance traditionnelle sans aller aussi
loin bien entendu et je précise que ce
caractère optionnel de l'agrément était
un choix assumé par la loi pacte afin de
ne pas limiter le développement de
l'écosystème et de ne pas repousser les
acteurs hors de France
nous c'est l'option qui a été prise à
l'époque était de d'inciter les acteurs
qui souhaitent jouer le jeu de la
régulation à venir le faire sur le
territoire français et comme je le
disais nous constatons que c'est un
succès assez réel puisque nous avons
aujourd'hui une soixantaine d'acteurs
qui sont enregistrés
à ce stade nous constatons également que
les acteurs ont préféré se tourner vers
l'enregistrement nous avons quelques
dossiers d'agrément dans le régime pacte
qui sont en cours d'instruction par les
services de l'AMF et nous nous efforçons
d'accompagner les acteurs vers ce cadre
qui apparaît dorénavant nécessaire au
regard des évolutions du secteur et qui
sera bientôt la norme au niveau européen
vous avez évoqué monsieur le Président
le les éléments qui ont marqué le monde
des crypto actifs depuis 5 ans je n'y
reviendrai pas donc dans le détail sauf
peut-être s'il y a des questions mais
effectivement
de dévalorisation qui ont été très
volatiles et impactés le défaut de
certains acteurs jusque et y compris le
cas FTX que vous avez évoqué et qui est
effectivement une affaire grave mais je
ne renie pas les propos que vous avez
cités effectivement ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il faut considérer que tout le
secteur doit être mis dans le dans le
même dans le même la même appréciation
et le monde de la finance digitale ne
doit pas être condamnée par FTX comme la
finance traditionnelle ne l'a pas été
par Madoff
pour répondre à tous ces enjeux l'Europe
a fait un pas significatif que nous
avons évidemment soutenu que la France a
été dans lequel la France a été porteuse
d'ailleurs avec l'adoption du règlement
Mika qui prévoit pour fin 2024 en
agrément obligatoire c'est pour cela que
je disais qu'effectivement le temps est
venu de se mettre en ordre de bataille
collectivement pour aller vers
l'agrément puisque c'est le régime
européen et qu'il s'imposera avec des
délais différents selon les cas à tous
les acteurs du secteur en Europe il
permettra l'harmonisation des pratiques
au sein de l'Union européenne
l'émergence de marché de crypto actifs
mieux encadrés avec notamment des règles
concernant les abus de marché un
développement facilité pour les acteurs
qui opère dans le secteur via la logique
de passeport européen qui prévaut dans
d'autres domaines donc ceux qui seront
agréés dans un pays de l'Union
européenne pourront effectivement
intervenir sur l'ensemble de l'Union
européenne donc c'est assez porteur
aussi ce régime permettra davantage de
protection pour les épargnants avec des
règles claires et une meilleure
information il est donc crucial comme
j'indique je l'indiquais pour le secteur
de passer à la vitesse supérieure qui
est
pardon qui est incarné par l'agrément
les discussions au Parlement à
l'occasion de la transposition des
divers textes européens donc le fameux
projet de loi d'adultes ont montré la
nécessité de monter les niveaux des
exigences du cadre français dans
l'optique du cadre européen de s'y
préparer et dans une approche de
meilleure protection des épargnants que
notamment le Sénat a souhaité donc le
dispositif adopté prévoir une extinction
assez rapide de l'enregistrement simple
et la mise en place d'un régime
intermédiaire qu'on appelle
enregistrement renforcé qui constitue
une marche significative vers l'agrément
et deviendra obligatoire pour les
nouveaux entrants en octobre 2024 et 18
mois plus tard pour les le secteurs qui
sont aujourd'hui enregistrés dans nos
livres
comme je l'ai déjà indiqué à ce cette
clause de grand-père qui était déjà
prévue n'est pas modifiée et donc les
les acteurs qui sont aujourd'hui
enregistrés auront 18 mois après
l'entrée en vigueur du dispositif
européen pour se préparer à l'agrément
ce passage a un cadre renforcé une
condition du retour de la confiance dans
l'écosystème crypto dans le contexte
compliqué que vous avez décrit monsieur
le Président il est considéré comme
essentiel pour la protection des
consommateurs comme pour la robustesse
du marché des crypto actifs de vérifier
notamment la sécurité et la résilience
des systèmes d'information d'epsan c'est
un sujet qui a fait l'objet de pas mal
de débats dans le cadre de du projet de
loi d'adultes et je suppose que vous
souhaiterez peut-être y revenir et donc
nous nous souhaitons effectivement
insister sur le fait que c'est un
élément pour nous important qui est prêt
qui était déjà prévu dans le cadre des
agréments mais qui n'avaient pas trouvé
à s'appliquer comme je l'indiquais et
qui trouvera donc à s'appliquer dans le
régime d'enregistrement amélioré l'enjeu
pour les autorités publiques et donc
pour l'AMF c'est d'accompagner cette
transition nous y travaillons dès
maintenant nous avons d'ores et déjà au
sein de l'AMF des équipes d'experts qui
connaissent bien ces acteurs et ses
marchés nous travaillons avec ces
acteurs et leurs associations notamment
la dent afin de clarifier ces nouvelles
règles et d'adapter les conditions
d'agrément actuel pour les rendre le
plus proche possible des dispositions
opérationnelles du nouveau règlement
européen
je dirais également avant de conclure
que l'AMF travaille également en étroite
collaboration avec les autorités
européennes et internationales
laisse-moi tout d'abord puisque il y a
lieu pour elle de préparer des textes
d'application du nouveau règlement
européen
donc ça c'est le premier étage je dirais
international c'est l'étage européen la
mise en œuvre de Mika mais je signale
aussi qu'il y a beaucoup de travaux au
niveau international peut-être la CPRI
reviendra également à la fois dans le
cas du forum de stabilité financière
mais pour ce qui nous concerne plus
directement au sein de l'organisation
internationale des commissions de valeur
l'OICV ou l'ensemble des régulateurs de
marché souhaite promouvoir une bonne
appréhension collective des risques et
de la convergence des régimes pour
assurer un terrain de jeu égal pour les
acteurs entre les zones géographiques
mais aussi mieux comprendre les risques
qui s'attachent à ce secteur
ses réflexions sont importantes et elles
témoignent à la fois du dynamisme du
marché
et des acteurs en France comme à
l'international les régulateurs doivent
s'en nourrir rencontrer les acteurs
comprendre les opportunités et les
risques et continuer sur la voie d'une
régulation que nous souhaitons agiles et
ouverte en consolidant et renforçant
notre expertise
vous ne concluez pas d'ailleurs parce
que vous conclure
et vous conclurez tout à l'heure merci
beaucoup si vous le voulez bien merci
merci madame la Présidente vous aurez
noté que comme vous avez eu un meuble
pour la Commission en démarrant j'ai été
plus large sur le temps mais comme les
autres ne l'auront pas on s'en tiendra
aux 10 minutes pour les si vous le
voulez bien nous allons passer
d'ailleurs
la parole à Madame Faustine Fleury en
tant que représentant de la dent qui
d'ailleurs pourra sans doute
comment dire peut-être passer l'aspect
plus réglementaire parce qu'il vient
d'être très largement évoqué par madame
la Présidente donc je vous propose de
nous donner surtout le point de vue de
la profession par rapport à
aux besoins qui sont qui sont les vôtres
finalement c'est une question qui nous
intéresse tous madame
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs merci beaucoup pour votre
invitation aujourd'hui pour cette
audition afin de vous parler
effectivement de cet équilibre
nécessaire entre la réglementation mais
aussi le développement d'une innovation
qui est déjà très présente en France et
aujourd'hui et que nous continuons
encourager au sein de l'association
quelques mots sur la dame l'Association
pour le développement des actifs
numériques que je représente et
président aujourd'hui nous sommes une
association professionnelle donc somme
toute classique qui représentons 200
entreprises qui évoluent dans cette
nouvelle économie du web décentralisée
nous avons vocation donc à la fédérer à
les représenter et apporter à leur voix
car nous sommes convaincus du potentiel
concernant l'emploi que ces entreprises
revêtent pour concernant la souveraineté
numérique que la France et l'Europe doit
préserver et de la compétitivité qui est
nécessaire de pouvoir maintenir et
notamment dans le cadre de débats
réglementaires
qui sont qui sont en cours ou
relativement avancés c'est pourquoi
parmi les axes de travail de
l'association du temps au niveau
français que européen nous avons
beaucoup peu vrai en faveur quand nous
avons toujours promu la nécessité d'une
réglementation qui soit protectrice du
l'utilisateur car les vecteurs de
l'adoption que nous prenons également et
du développement sain des marchés pour
autant que cette réglementation soit
proportionnée adaptée car c'est
seulement de cette façon là qu'elle sera
efficace et donc tous ces travaux sont
bien sûr menés de façon totalement
étroite et et constructive avec les
autorités en France et en Europe
donc l'association représente une
nouvelle économie sur la page suivante
je souhaite vous faire un état des lieux
assez rapides mais néanmoins complets de
cette innovation nous avons mené l'an
dernier et monsieur le Président vous
avez d'ailleurs cité un chiffre qui
émane de cette étude voilà une étude sur
l'état des lieux de cette industrie et
l'état de l'adoption en France des
crypto actifs et du web 3 donc vous
pourrez retrouver des des chiffres sous
vos yeux le message principal est ici et
de vous montrer que cette industrie est
aujourd'hui réputée cette industrie
française et toujours du réputée pour
son dynamisme au sein de l'Union
européenne mais également dans le monde
vous le savez peut-être cette nouvelle
économie du web 3 compte 2 licornes qui
entraînent derrière elle un très large
terreau d'entreprise petit et moyennes
qui vont développer ces cas d'usage le
chiffre de 600 projets en France est un
chiffre de BPI France qui aurait pu
faire cette cette estimation vous pouvez
également voir que l'industrie française
est génératrice d'emploi et sur
l'ensemble de nos territoires puisque
sur la carte précédente que vous pouviez
voir des membres de l'association vous
pouvez voir qu'il y a une implantation
dans l'ensemble de la France de cette
nouvelle économie et donc des emplois
qui sont ainsi générés nous avons pu par
cette étude savoir que l'ensemble des
quasiment l'ensemble des entreprises
cherchent à recruter et majoritairement
en France ce qui est une excellente
nouvelle pour nous pour nos territoires
enfin et cela a été largement déjà
évoqué pas de par les travaux
réglementaires avancés en France et en
Europe l'industrie française est réputée
parmi les plus la plus sérieuse et les
plus crédibles au sein de l'Union
européenne et dans le monde
sur la page suivante je souhaitais cela
a été évoquer vous partager assez de
façon plus ou moins exhaustive la plus
complète possible la date mais les cas
d'usage que vous pouvez trouver derrière
ces nouvelles technologies des blocs
chaîne et des crypto actifs les cas
d'usages qui vous intéresse et au sein
de son commission sont les cas d'usage
financiers néanmoins il est quand même
très important de noter que cette
innovation technologique finalement
ruisselle dans de nombreux segments
économiques à des stades de maturité
extrêmement différents donc sous vos
yeux vous avez quelques exemples si vous
prenez le secteur finance vous avez
comme vous le voyez au sein de
l'assurance de la banque des paiements
des nouvelles des nouveaux cas d'usage
qui se développent et une façon plus
efficiente de rendre des services qui
peuvent exister aujourd'hui mais voilà
si nous devons citer également des cas
d'usage non financier vous pouvez voir
que dans la suite du jeu vidéo
l'ensemble des marques dans le sport
dans le secteur de d'énergie etc ce sont
également des technologies qui vont être
utilisées et donc il est important de
noter que en tant que innovation
transversale elle touche aujourd'hui et
touchera demain finalement le l'ensemble
du quotidien de nos citoyens ce qui me
permet de par sur la page suivante vous
parler de l'adoption des crypto actifs
en France et l'approche de la France en
matière de crypto et de web 3 qui a été
en faveur du développement de
l'innovation dans un environnement sûr
pour les utilisateurs a permis
effectivement qu'aujourd'hui nous ayons
déjà 8% de Français qui est qui ont
adopté cette innovation et 30% qui
considèrent acquérir des crypto actifs
c'est pourquoi il est extrêmement
important que ce public français puisse
se tourner vers des Champions en France
et en Europe pour souscrire à ses
services pour acquérir ces crypto actifs
plutôt que de se tourner vers des
acteurs étrangers qui vont pour la
plupart être beaucoup moins sûr à ce
titre on peut effectivement regretter
que que des acteurs comme FTX et pu être
accessible à au public français la
problématique que nous avons c'est que
nous avons seulement 9% des Français qui
ont investi dans les crypto-actifs qui
connaissaient effectivement la
réglementation française donc là le son
que nous devons tirer c'est que cette
réglementation est évidemment nécessaire
pour la protection de l'épargnant pour
d'autres objectifs comme la lutte contre
la criminalité financière par exemple
néanmoins il faut absolument que nous
ayons une industrie qui soit également
compétitive pour que nos champions nos
entreprises soient également enfin soit
choisi par nos citoyens pour pour
bénéficier de ces de ces nouveaux
services qui leur sont qui leur sont
tendus
sur les pages suivantes je vous l'avais
effectivement revenir mais je vais le
faire plus rapidement sur l'avancement
de la réglementation mais avec des
messages très positifs mais qui ont déjà
pu être diffusés à savoir que la France
compte le cadre aujourd'hui le plus
abouti en Europe même dans le monde en
matière de réglementation des marchés de
crypto actifs je tiens à rappeler que
cette innovation est très jeune puisque
elle est née dans les années 2008-2009
et pour autant nous avons déjà beaucoup
beaucoup achevés du point de vue de la
réglementation aujourd'hui en France et
cela a été rappelé à travers la mise en
place de la loi pacte nous avons un
cadre pour les intermédiaires de marché
de crypto actifs marcher primaire et
marcher secondaire à travers le visa Ico
et l'enregistrement obligatoire et
l'agrément optionnel d'epsan mais
peut-être moins connu nous avons
également beaucoup peuvré sur la
fiscalité des crypto actifs avec les
ajustements qui étaient nécessaires de
mettre en place ainsi qu'au niveau de
l'industrie des fonds pour les
possibilité de certains de ces actifs à
certains font notamment professionnels
mais ça c'est très connu aujourd'hui
nous avons également beaucoup et l'année
2023 sera charnière à ce stade beaucoup
encore attendre de pas pour l'évolution
de ce cadre d'ailleurs et peut-être
intéressant de noter que le régime San a
été déjà renforcé par deux fois et le
sera cette année encore alors qu'il est
relativement très récent nous attendons
donc un renforcement de l'enregistrement
d'epsan en au premier jeu juillet 2023
ce qui pose bien sûr énormément de
questions et nous avançons avec les
autorités pour que du point de vue
opérationnel la transition se fasse la
plus fluidement possible pour pour les
acteurs qui seront concernés mais vous
le voyez il y a énormément de réflexions
également sur des pans de l'innovation
qui n'ont pas forcément été adressées
aujourd'hui par la réglementation que ce
soit les acteurs qui ont recours à des
jetons très particuliers que l'on
appelle les jetons non fongibles ou NFC
sur l'aspect communication et promotion
des objectifs nous pouvons noter un
certain nombre de travaux également qui
sont très importants la proposition de
loi actuellement
débattus dites influenceurs qui concerne
les crypto actifs mais aussi des travaux
que nous avons menés de façon étroite en
fin de l'année dernière avec l'autorité
régulation professionnelle de la
publicité pour justement admet de
meilleures pratiques dans l'écosystème
que ceux qui existent aujourd'hui la
question de l'impact environnemental est
bien sûr une question que beaucoup se
posent et nous serons bien évidemment
disponibles pour répondre à aux
questions si cela si cela était
nécessaire et enfin nous avons aussi
enfin bien que nous ayons avancé sur la
fiscalité des crypto actifs de
nombreuses clarifications sont encore
nécessaires et nous y avons également
sur cette page très rapidement c'est
pour vous situer
le positionnement de la France par
rapport à l'avancement de sa
réglementation mais aussi la maturité de
son écosystème je rappelle que c'est
l'industrie principalement composée de
nouveaux entrants néanmoins au sein de
l'Union européenne séparé l'industrie la
plus dynamique et la plus développée
ainsi que l'état de sa réglementation
qui a été très très précurseur et qui a
d'ailleurs inspiré beaucoup d'autres
cadres
au sein de au sein de l'Union européenne
mais qui inspire même aujourd'hui dans
d'autres grandes régions du monde comme
les Etats-Unis les réflexions pour pour
la mise en place d'une réglementation
que nous appelons de notre vœu être
international à être harmonisé par
essence les actifs numériques le web 3
est une trans frontières et il va il
faut absolument que les bonnes pratiques
et les standards que nous avons promis
au niveau national et européen soit
étendu pour que cette
pour que les objectifs que nous
recherchons par rapport à cette
réglementation soit finalement atteint
et que nous protégeons effectivement
l'épargnant quel que soit le
l'acteur vers laquelle il se tourne de
par le monde
sur la dernière page que je vous soumets
aujourd'hui mais cela aussi été évoqué
l'Europe a également c'était également
saisi du sujet de la réglementation des
marchés de crypto actif et il faut noter
de ce point de vue là le rôle
extrêmement moteur de la France qui de
par ses travaux précurseurs a souhaité
les pérenniser et les étendre et
harmoniser les règles qui ont été bâties
dans l'ensemble de l'espace économique
européen parmi les textes les plus
aboutis et qui arrivent extrêmement vite
cela a été cité mais le règlement Mika
qui s'inspire de l'agrément en français
va entrer en vigueur ce semestre pour
entrer en application en 2024 ce qui est
une excellente nouvelle pour nos
entreprises de voir les conditions de
concurrence harmoniser au sein de
l'Union européenne pour que cela soit
réellement efficace il ne faudra pas
oublier que que nous avons besoin aussi
d'une supervision qui soit efficace et
opérationnelle en pratique je ne
reviendrai pas non plus sur le régime
pilote qui arrive encore plus vite
puisque entre en application ce mois-ci
il faut aussi noter dans les travaux qui
ont été beaucoup aboutis aujourd'hui
tous les travaux relatifs à la lutte
contre le blanchiment et le financement
du théorisme puisque c'est souvent
reproché aux crypto actifs à savoir que
ce sont des vecteurs de blanchiment et
de financement du terrorisme ce n'est
pas du tout le cas du point de vue
technologique mais en plus sur ce volet
de la réglementation à la fois en France
et en Europe nous avons largement
œuvré pour que pour que les
réglementations adaptées s'appliquent
s'applique à ces marchés demain à mise à
part ces textes là et notamment Mika et
la réforme lutte contre le blanchiment
et le financement du terrorisme nous
attendons énormément de textes qui vont
s'appliquer aux acteurs de marché qui
doivent déjà s'y préparer qui doivent
déjà l'anticiper et sur lequel la France
est également moteur dans dans la
définition de certaines règles que nous
attendons des innovations sur lesquelles
les réflexions doivent être menées de
façon plus long terme puisque ce sont
des innovations les plus récentes mais
aussi j'ai voté des âges ces sujets sur
le point du français
relatifs à l'environnement la
cybersécurité la fiscalité tous ces
travaux vont être également menés au
niveau européen et nous devons
absolument et il faut absolument que
l'industrie soit impliquée pour que
encore une fois si cette réglementation
doit être efficace il faut qu'elle soit
adaptée aux spécificités de ces marchés
et proportionner à l'état de maturité et
à la taille de de cette nouvelle
économie voilà je vous remercie pour
votre attention et je me tiens à votre
disposition pour des questions que vous
pourriez avoir
je vous remercie madame fleuret je vais
peut-être inverser les les deux
suivantes peut-être puisqu'on est sur
les entreprises et la vision
professionnelle je vais demander à
Monsieur Louvet peut-être de de prendre
la suite si il le veut bien et je
demanderai ensuite à Monsieur Perret
peut-être après aussi ce qu'il a entendu
de
de nous dire son propos
merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs ma présidente monsieur
secrétaire général
j'ai le plaisir de vous donner une
vision économique business de ce de ce
métier
de cette activité qui nous
occupe qui nous qui nous passionne et
qui représente aujourd'hui une forte
opportunité pour pour la France pour nos
économies il en va de la transformation
aussi d'une partie de notre industrie
financière et du monde des paiements et
donc de notre indépendance numérique
sujet qui qui me semble est un est un
véritable sujet pour pour les années à
venir je le propose les discussions
récentes sur Tik Tok par exemple
qui font qui font grand bruit
tout d'abord une
une cartographie ou une carte d'identité
de
cohenhouse qui sommes-nous en une
société française un basée basée à Paris
on s'appelait La Maison du Bitcoin vous
aviez eu l'occasion en 2018 je crois
ça faisait un peu la Maison du Chocolat
mais mais l'idée était quand même assez
incroyable de de créer un lieu un lieu
assez unique en 2014 pour parler de
blockchain et Bitcoin et c'est surtout
un lieu qui a permis de créer de
nombreuses sociétés Ledger mais
également à 5 dans les technologies et
bien d'autres entreprises sont passées
par par la Maison du Bitcoin pas mal de
d'investisseurs ils sont passés ont
gagné beaucoup beaucoup d'argent en
achetant des crypto monnaie à des prix
particulièrement enfin d'échanges toute
concurrence en 2014 et 2015
on a fait une spin-off de Ledger en 2017
là où j'ai sur entré dans dans le jeu en
tant que PDG on a levé depuis une
cinquantaine de millions d'euros ce qui
fait parmi nous
parmi les acteurs les plus les plus
actifs en matière de levée de fonds dans
le domaine fintech et notamment dans le
domaine propre à la crypto monnaie
la Société Générale nous fait confiance
depuis de nombreuses années et je pense
qu'on est un peu une exception dans
cette dans cet écosystème mais comme
Faustine le disait il faut que les
acteurs traditionnels du monde bancaire
s'intéressent de plus en plus et
travaille de plus en plus avec le monde
San on a absolument besoin
d'acteurs bancaires pour soutenir nos
activités et on a créé des emplois à
nous étions cinq en 2017
on est 120 en fin 2022 tous ces emplois
étaient créés en France il s'agit
d'emploi qui est lycée et l'objectif est
bien sûr
de booster cette création d'emplois dans
les années à venir je vais pas m'étendre
sur le cadre réglementaire puisque ça a
déjà été évoqué je m'inscris dans toutes
les propos qui ont été tenus par Madame
la prison de l'AMF et par la précédente
de la dame nous on a particularité on a
été le premier acteur enregistré c'était
en mars 2020 donc quelques mois
seulement après la publication des
décrets de la loi pacte qui instauré le
régime San puisqu'on aime bien la
régulation on a décidé aussi d'aller
s'enregistrer au Luxembourg auprès de la
CSSF ça c'était en décembre 2021 on est
en démarche pour
l'enregistrement l'agrément pardon
San et on fait partie d'un des membres
fondateurs de la dan on travaille depuis
de nombreuses années sur les sujets
réglementaires et notamment sur les
travaux qui ont permis de d'élaborer
d'élaborer Mika
notre activité vous l'aviez dit en fait
la crypto étant en phase de
révolutionner bien bien des aspects du
monde de la finance elle trouve un des
applications dans la finance
traditionnelle à travers la tokenisation
la possibilité d'aller mettre un actif
financier traditionnel dans un jeton qui
va circuler sur une blockchain et bien
nous on s'inscrit pleinement dans cette
démarche et aujourd'hui
quand une house vend des crypto actifs
du Bitcoin de l'éther un certain nombre
mais demain dès lors qu'on aura les bons
agréments on se voit comme l'acteur
capable d'aller
commercialiser
conseiller les invest les investisseurs
sur toute actifs stockés alors bien sûr
ça nécessitera peut-être un agrément de
société de gestion ou d'entreprises
d'investissement mais demain une action
un produit immobilier tokenisé bah c'est
à travers cohenhouse que vous allez
pouvoir y accéder on se définit comme un
nouveau modèle bancaire une
transformation et comme les crypto c'est
pas seulement des actifs volatils mais
ça peut être aussi des actifs qui
servent à réaliser des opérations de
paiement et bien on se voit aussi comme
un processeur de paiement si demain une
monnaie digitale de banque centrale ou
tout autre monnaie
tokenisé étant libre circulation et
permet d'acheter des biens comme c'est
possible déjà de le faire vous pouvez
acheter un NFC qui est un autre bien
numérique mais vous pouvez d'ores et
déjà commencer à acheter des produits
physiques avec certaines crypto monnaie
ça a pas forcément un intérêt majeur en
France mais ça en a dans d'autres pays
et c'est des choses aussi qui vont se
démocratiser et bien nous on se
positionne aussi dans cet élément
du coup notre rôle est vraiment dans
l'accompagnement de la transformation de
l'industrie de la finance et des
paiements à travers les crypto d'où
l'importance de la régulation on ne peut
pas imaginer changer le monde bancaire
ou changer le monde des paiements sont
suivre une base de la régulation qui est
associée à ces assez industries qui sont
bien spécifiques ça a toujours été dans
notre idée depuis
2017 et c'est toute la démarche qui nous
a amené à travailler sur la construction
de la régulation à travailler avec des
régulateurs en France et en Europe et à
participer au développement de la dame
pour parler plus concrètement
aujourd'hui on a deux grosses activités
la première sert vraiment les
investisseurs particuliers et
entreprises on les oublie souvent mais
les entreprises sont des des acteurs
aussi de cet écosystème des clients à la
fois pour monde des paiements mais aussi
pour la diversification de de leurs
excédent de trésorerie et on les
accompagne justement dans la plateforme
d'investissement de ces crypto la
possibilité d'acheter d'échanger des
crypto avec des moyens bancaires
traditionnels une carte bancaire ou en
lisant un virement bancaire dans
quelques mois on devrait normalement
sous le goût de la CPR devenir l'agent
d'un établissement de paiement et donc
commencer à proposer un compte en euros
à nos clients et donc d'avoir la dualité
vous pouvez avoir un compte en euros
comme vous pouvez l'avoir sur une
néobank classique par donnez-moi du
terme et également la possibilité
d'avoir des crypto du coup vous pouvez
beaucoup plus facilement passer d'un
monde à l'autre ça nous semble être
quelque chose d'assez intéressant on a
un modèle assez différent des acteurs
étrangers ou d'autres acteurs français
on vise une clientèle qui est plutôt une
clientèle d'épargnant et pour cela on a
mis en place une offre d'accompagnement
dites Premium qui permet en fait à ses
clients d'avoir des chargés de compte un
peu comme vos chargés de compte bancaire
ou gestion de patrimoine qui vont
réellement vous conseiller donc on a des
2018 mis en place l'équivalent de
questionnaires mi-fit pour questionner
les clients sur leur patrimoine sur leur
appétit au risque pour mieux les
connaître de façon à les conseiller sur
leurs investissement crypto parce que on
pense que les crypto sont des belles
opportunités de diversification de
l'épargne mais ça reste de la
diversification ça reste très risqué ce
n'est pas adapté à tout type
d'investisseurs et bien évidemment on
doit l'avoir de façon proportionnée moi
j'y vais de façon un peu sérieuse et
peut-être parfois un peu trop par
rapport à ma mon épargne personnelle
mais on recommande généralement aux
clients d'avoir quelques pourcents 5 à
10% et puis au client les plus fortunés
qui ont une grosse base éventuellement
de mettre des montants plus importants
toutes les crypto qu'on propose on
propose deux bases la possibilité de les
conserver de façon sécurisée
majoritairement call storage
c'est-à-dire dans des systèmes qui sont
non connectés à Internet qui sont à
froid donc la possibilité d'aller
chercher ses crypto et
complexe puisqu'elle n'est pas associée
à la possibilité de faire un hack
informatique et c'est pour ça je crois
qu'on a également été l'un des seuls
acteurs qui depuis deux ans et demi
disposent d'une assurance auprès d'un
acteur français qui est la MMA et qui
couvre nos activités d'investissement de
d'investissement et de conservation de
crypto parallèlement à ça on prend ce
que c'est extrêmement pertinent d'avoir
un peu de crypto dans son patrimoine
mais pour beaucoup de Français ça reste
très compliqué quelle crypto choisir
quand est-ce qu'il faut investir est-ce
que c'est le bon moment de rentrer sur
Bitcoin ou Esther et ce qu'il vaut mieux
le vendre l'arbitrer contre un stable
tout ça est assez compliqué et en fait
dans la finance traditionnelle qui reste
quand même notre référence de base on
s'aperçoit que beaucoup
d'épargnants notamment français européen
vont préférer de la gestion d'actifs on
va faire confiance à de l'assurance vie
on va faire confiance à des
gestionnaires qui vont gérer pour vous
on pense que les crypto vont aller dans
cet élément et on pense un des gros
éléments qui pourraient d'ailleurs
booster l'assurance vie c'est de
proposer quelques pourcents dans les
assurances vie dans des crypto actifs à
ce titre la BRI a validé la possibilité
pour les banques commerciales d'avoir
jusqu'à 2% de crypto actifs à leur bilan
à partir de 2025 ce qui montre aussi
qu'il y a une institutionnalisation et
un intérêt des grandes banques pour le
monde de la de la crypto en France on
peut compter Société Générale Amundi BNP
qui s'intéresse d'ores et déjà avec des
équipes sur ces éléments mais aux
États-Unis c'est Blackrock Jeepy Morgan
qui propose de la crypto alors à leurs
clients donc on construit aussi ces
éléments on a construit des produits
d'épargne vous aurez peut-être des
questions sur les livrets crypto
qui ont été impactés chez nous par la
faillite de FTX et les défauts d'autres
contreparties je laisserai ces éléments
pour un peu plus tard on a un autre
grand pan d'activité qui a émergé
l'année dernière c'est des solutions
pour les activités web 3 et le paiement
en crypto pour tout entreprises qui veut
développer une stratégie web 3 et donc
commencer à partir de Smart contracte je
pense que vous avez une formation par un
professeur d'université avant donc
j'espère que vous savez ce que c'est
qu'un Smart contracte mais c'est la
capacité d'aller programmer
voilà donc quel élément Smart c'est
l'élément à retenir et contracte on va
dire que c'est un algorithme vous pouvez
programmer en fait un jeton et lui
donner des propriétés et lui faire
réaliser des fonctions automatiquement
sur l'intervention d'un être humain
avec chat GPT vous pouvez imaginer ce
que vous pouvez faire avec avec la
combinaison de l'IA et et des smart
contracts le grand intérêt de tout ça
c'est que si vous voulez produire des
éléments dans les dans le web 3 il faut
nécessairement que les interactions avec
des objets web 3 se fera avec des jetons
et des crypto monnaie ce qui veut dire
qu'une grande entreprise par exemple du
secteur du luxe et on a en France des
leaders mondiaux dans ce domaine qui
veut lancer des projets dans le web 3 va
recevoir des paiements en crypto actif
et c'est la seule possibilité vous ne
pouvez pas faire entrer une carte
bancaire ou un paiement en euros dans un
objet digital qui fonctionne sur une
blockchain ça ne marche pas si vous le
faites vous cassez tout l'intérêt et
vous recréez de la centralisation vous
recréer des coûts là où
l'envoi d'un élément d'un Wallet à un
autre qui qui correspond à un paiement
permet de faire toutes les
fonctionnalités en quelques secondes à
des coûts qui sont moindres donc il y a
un fort intérêt de de digitaliser et les
la relation client et d'utiliser ces
technologies pour elle et forcément
elles ont besoin d'acteurs comme nous
qui sont qui sommes régulés pour pouvoir
accepter ses paiements web 3 et pouvoir
permettre de gérer la conformité et
toutes les options de paiement il y a un
gros business et une belle opportunité
de révolutionner le monde des paiements
avec les crypto et on veut absolument se
positionner dans cet élément pour aller
un peu
pour conclure cette première partie ce
sera mon dernier slide bon pour une
année quelques informations financières
donc on a un nombre de comptes qui est
assez faible eu égard à la taille du
marché global qui représente plus de 200
millions d'utilisateurs dans le monde
dans les dans les cryptos mais on a une
clientèle plutôt Premium avec un
investissement moyen de notre clientèle
Premium qui est plutôt important donc on
a
la possibilité de conserver des
centaines de millions d'euros dans nos
équivalents dans nos systèmes on reste
quand même très focalisé sur la France
mais l'objectif c'est de conquérir
l'Europe et on a pour ça le besoin de
soutien de la régulation et et de l'État
pour nous pour nous accompagner 45% de
chiffre d'affaires a été réalisé par les
entreprises je pense que c'est un
élément qui est important de vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas juste des
particuliers geeks qui s'intéressent à
la crypto mais en fait c'est des bons
paires de famille qui s'intéressent à la
crypto c'est des entreprises qui
s'intéressent à la crypto et on a a eu
l'occasion la chance de signer des beaux
partenariats avec des belles entreprises
françaises ou internationales et on a
une ambition très forte dans le dans le
domaine je resterai là parce que je
pense que vous avez des questions et
vous avez d'autres slides qui couvrent
des aspects liés à l'énergie à la
gestion de la criminalité ou aux aspects
crypto plus criminalité à nos réactions
aussi par rapport aux problématiques
récentes connues dans le dans le marché
ou ne positionnements sur la régulation
française et européenne mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs je vous remercie
merci
monsieur monsieur
Louvet donc je me tourne maintenant vers
Monsieur Bertrand Perret donc de
l'Autorité de contrôle prudentiel et de
résolution
qui viendra compléter j'imagine les
propos de Madame balayani et peut-être
aussi à la lumière de ce qu'il a entendu
de la part des
entreprises du secteur vous avez la
parole
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
comme on parle du même sujet je vais
essayer de réduire ma présentation
puisque beaucoup de choses ont été dites
je partage d'ailleurs beaucoup de choses
que Marianne a dit notamment sur le
caractère de l'innovation ceci étant
j'aurais un biais en tant que
superviseur un peu plus sur la partie
contrôle et maîtrise des risques
d'ailleurs axe qui est probablement
partagé par par la MF je vais essayer
d'éviter les risques de répétition mais
ce sera quand même l'occasion de vous
donner la tonalité de la CPR dans ce
domaine donc autour de la maîtrise des
risques de de
qui qui gravite autour de l'usage de ce
que nous appelons absolument pas une
crypto monnaie notamment la Banque de
France mais un crypto actif quoi qu'il
arrive on y reviendra sur le sujet si
vous le souhaitez donc nous on considère
que en France on a quand même fait un
choix précoce donc relativement à
d'autres à d'autres juridictions pour
encadrer le marché des crypto actif et
d'ailleurs en partenariat avec
l'industrie comme ça a été évoqué parce
que tout le monde y a un intérêt et que
la loi pacte que vous connaissez aussi
bien que moi donc à donner un rôle à la
CPR en matière de supervision qui vient
compléter le rôle de de l'AMF et
notamment en commençant d'ailleurs par
l'enregistrement donc si vous voulez la
l'encadrement des risques qui est venu
d'autant plus sur le sur le devant de la
scène que à un certain nombre
d'intervenants comme on l'a évoqué on
fait faillite ces derniers temps et donc
nous ne considérons que pour avoir un
développement durable donc des crypto
actifs il faut une réglementation
adaptée
alors c'est d'autant plus nécessaire que
on l'a évoqué sa touche un nombre
important de la population le chiffre
d'aménage sur 10 a été cité 8% de la
population a été cité donc s'il y a 30
millions de ménages en France ça fait 3
millions d'usagers si c'est 8% des
Français ça nous fait 5 millions 4 bref
toujours est-il que nous on remarque
dans les études qui ont été fait
notamment par la Banque centrale
européenne que les populations qui sont
intéressées par par les crypto en fait
forment une courbe en U vous avez à la
fois les acteurs qui sont les moins
fortunés et les acteurs qui sont les
plus fortunés qui interviennent sur ce
dispositif les choses évoluent peut-être
comme le disait donc monsieur Louvet
avec avec des développements récents en
tout cas les derniers éléments dont nous
disposons sont ceux-là et à l'instar de
notre rôle en matière de protection des
déposants dans le cadre de la
supervision bancaire nous sommes bien
entendu sensibles aux risques
qu'encourts des investisseurs ou des
déposants dans le domaine donc des
crypto actifs
on intervient dans le domaine donc de
l'enregistrement des des acteurs de de
ce secteur dans deux domaines la lcbft
et notamment pour ceux dont les services
qui sont octroyés les clientèle consiste
à pouvoir convertir des crypto actifs en
monnaie Fiat c'est à dire en une devise
l'euro ou le ou le dollar sachant qu'il
y a d'autres services que font les psan
de crypto contre crypto conservation etc
dès lors que vous avez un lien qui était
établi entre le crypto lui-même et une
monnaie Fiat à ce moment-là nous nous
intervenons dans l'examen du dispositif
de lutte contre le blanchiment de la
même manière que nous complétons
l'analyse que fait la MF sur la comme on
disait en anglais c'est le feat androper
donc c'est sur lequel la qualité à la
fois des dirigeants et des et des et des
actionnaires principaux donc en
complétant l'analyse ou la de la MF à
travers à travers nos bases
quand on parle de
dispositif de lutte contre le
blanchiment et de gel des avoir auquel
donc sont soumis ces instances
c'est d'abord un examen qui se fait sur
pièce à partir donc des documentations
que nous transmettent les PSN à la fois
sur la gouvernance du risque sur les
profils de clients qu'ils ont et des
risques associés à ces profils de
clients j'y reviendrai et puis aussi les
schémas possibles de blanchiment donc
des outils qui dit transactionnels qui
observent les transactions qui sont
faites afin de détecter ces éléments
dans un premier temps on les apprécie
sur pièce sachant que si on a une focale
très importante sur la lutte contre le
blanchiment c'est que à la fois en
France mais aussi au niveau du GAFI
nous avons considéré que
l'espace de transaction offert par des
plateformes sur des crypto actifs était
une source de risque extrêmement
importante en termes de blanchiment je
ne dis pas que toute opération qui sont
faites sur ces plateformes en cette
vocation je dis que ces plateformes sont
susceptibles d'être utilisées à l'insu
de leur plein gré on va dire ça comme ça
comme étant des vecteurs de blanchiment
ou de financement du terrorisme ce qui
est là aussi très ennuyeux
donc pour citer quelques exemples on dit
que les crypto sont utilisés sur le Dark
web sur le Deep web les cryptos servent
souvent de
de
symboles de règlement d'une rançon dans
le cadre de rançon jicielles qui bloque
les données d'une entreprise et donc
l'ergonomie de de l'environnement des
cryptos c'est à dire la blockchain
permet des transferts de fonds
extrêmement rapides que un système
bancaire ne permettrait pas en tout cas
sans laisser beaucoup plus de traces que
n'en laisse les crypto quand bien même
en dehors de certains des actifs qui
sont très très anonymisés permettent en
principe même si c'est quand même très
difficile mais on le voit à l'étranger
notamment le FBI qu'avec qui récupère
des montants très significatifs de font
voler dans le cadre de cyberattaque
parce que les crypto ne sont pas à
l'abri eux-mêmes en tout cas des
plateformes d'actes de malveillance
par rapport aux actifs qu'elles peuvent
détenir
donc cet enregistrement et notre rôle en
matière d'examen d'exécutif de lutte
contre le blanchiment un deuxième volet
c'est le contrôle sur place le contrôle
sur place pour vous donner donc un
exemple
sur les trois contrôles sur place que
nous avons mené les dernières deux ont
donné lieu à une radiation des PSN ces
publics puisque ça a été publié par
l'AMF donc c'est bikes et Emmanuel
management
les psan sont un point d'attention donc
du superviseur nos priorités pour
l'année 2023 ont été publié récemment
madame secrétaire général Nathalie au
Fauvre récemment donc en poste à fait
une interview dans les échos où elle
expose aussi ses priorités d'action de
la CPR et figure parmi ces priorités
bien entendu le contrôle des psan pour
s'assurer que ce qui nous est dit est
bien mis en place la bonne foi se
présume mais la confiance n'exclut pas
le contrôle donc nous allons sur place
pour vérifier si ce qui était sur des
est effectivement donc déployer dans les
établissements voilà ce que je peux dire
en conclusion et pour résumer donc nous
on a identifié de même que le GAFI est
le col donc le comité de place sur la
lutte contre le blanchiment comme enfin
cette activité sur les crypto actif
étant comme étant une source potentielle
de risque de financement du terrorisme
et du blanchiment donc et aussi comme je
l'évoquais des plateformes qui sont
susceptibles d'être victimes de
cyberattaque donc nous portons un un
accent particulier sur sur la chose et
effectivement comme l'évoque et Marianne
nous participons à la mise en oeuvre de
Mika donc ces textes européens sur
marketing crypto crypto à 7 parce que
nous avons donc un intérêt important à
ce que le dispositif soit soit bien
régulé et encore une fois je le répète
ça se fait donc
collaboration avec la dent avec nous
avons des contacts des contacts donc
dense chacun dans son rôle avec son
approche une approche naturellement de
développement de l'activité mais ça veut
pas dire que il n'est pas conscience de
leur risque et une approche qui est un
petit peu plus voire carrément plus
orienté sur sur les risques et je
finirai là-dessus nous sommes tout à
fait
content de l'équilibre auquel le
Parlement est arrivé sur le renforcement
de l'enregistrement encore une fois je
disais en introduction nous avons été
précurseurs dans le domaine par rapport
à d'autres géologie diction il est vrai
que ACPr nous étions plutôt favorables
carrément au passage à l'agrément qui
permet d'avoir une un dispositif
beaucoup plus large et beaucoup plus
complet notamment par rapport à la
protection des acteurs et notamment
particulier qui qui ont une activité sur
crypto actif ceci étant en ayant un
enregistrement renforcé et notamment
avec un volet renforcé sur
la sécurité cyber on fait déjà un pas
dans la protection des déposants pas qui
n'empêchera pas ce qui a été un facteur
permissif pour FTX d'utiliser les actifs
de ces déposants pour ses propres
opérations qui étaient un des éléments
parmi lesquels
ont trouvé enfin la faillite de cette
organisme à trouver ses racines voilà je
vous remercie pour votre attention et je
suis naturellement prêt à répondre à vos
questions merci Monsieur Perret
ce rapporteur général
je voulais m'associer aux remerciements
du président qui les a fait par
anticipation pour les
je dirais différentes
interventions et ou témoignages sur
finalement je dirais un peu un secteur
d'activité nouveau
qui continue de d'interroger
je pense nos concitoyens et bien sûr
nous même également
j'aurais pour une fois
plusieurs questions au nombre de quatre
et je veux revenir puisque c'était la
fin des propos du secrétaire général de
la CPR concernant la protection des
épargnants puisqu'en fait
ayant produit des travaux récemment avec
une pépel on s'était penché sur les
produits financiers traditionnels
il n'empêche que les crypto actifs en
fait on observe qu'ils ont davantage
progresser que les Alices boursiers en
2022 et ils ont tendance vous avez parlé
de la courbe en U à attirer pour les
particuliers des investisseurs et
notamment des jeunes investisseurs
malheureusement avec des rendements
assez faibles pour les investisseurs
particuliers
puisqu'il semblerait que ce soit surtout
les gros acteurs qui soient
les comment dire je les plus grands
bénéficiaires des variations de cours
comment est-ce que vous expliquez cette
engouement pour des actifs volatils
notamment par rapport à l'intérêt qui
pourrait être celui d'être plutôt sur la
bourse
toujours sur ce sujet la progression
finalement
observée d'une progression de plus en
plus rapide de produits à rendement avec
des livrets basés sur les crypto actifs
qu'elles en sont les risques et
avantages qu'elle regarde les autorités
de supervision portent-elles sur
développement notamment par rapport à
l'absence de garantie sur leur dépôt
troisième élément on l'a évoqué non pas
mais avec le l'exposé précédent sur la
grande consommation d'énergie charlongée
on a parlé notamment liée à l'activité
de minage le l'an dernier le
vice-président de l'ESMA avait même
estimé que les régulateurs devaient
éventuellement envisager d'interdire
l'un des modes d'extraction du Bitcoin
pour les plus énergivores celui basé sur
la preuve de travail
quel regard vous portez sur cette
proposition est-ce qu'elle vous paraît
réaliste et
quels sont les alternatives possibles
pour puisque c'est pas à la mode selon
moi il faut verdir
la production donc comment vous voyez
les évolutions possibles et puis enfin
on vient de parler beaucoup de finances
mais on observe que les technologies
sous-jacentes sont de plus en plus
utilisées dans d'autres domaines la
santé l'art les jeux
pouvez-vous nous expliquer les
applications fonctionnelles appelées à
se développer sur les crypto actifs et
selon vous dans quel domaine d'activité
merci Monsieur potageral Hervé Moret
puis Vincent Segouin
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
effectivement vous l'avez rappelé
plusieurs intervenants l'ont rappelé le
le Parlement a profité de ce fameux
d'Adult pour
renforcer la régulation des crypto
actifs c'est une bonne chose et d'autant
plus que rien n'était prévu dans le
texte qui nous a été transmis que le
gouvernement n'était pas du tout
favorable à ce que l'on fasse ce que
l'on a fait mais l'objectif c'était
justement de ne pas attendre la mise en
oeuvre de la directive Mika qui prendra
effet en 2024 avec possibilité de de
d'effets réels en 2026 pour les
entreprises déjà enregistrées et donc on
a au Sénat je le rappelle prévu donc cet
agrément anticipé finalement on a trouvé
pour pas être trop long un accord avec
l'Assemblée nationale sur un
enregistrement renforcé et on a obtenu
que l'Assemblée nationale accepte ce qui
n'était pas le cadre ce qu'il a évoqué
que parmi les critères de cet
enregistrement renforcé il y a les
critères de sécurité informatique et
c'est très important parce que je crois
vous vous me confirmerez ou non le
chiffre que les les cybers attaquent sur
les crypto actifs aurait représenté
quand même 4 milliards de dollars au
niveau mondial en 2022 donc ça n'est pas
ça n'est pas anodin et nous avons aussi
obtenu contre l'Assemblée nationale en
commission mixparitaire que ce
dispositif renforcé il s'applique dès le
premier juillet 2023 donc très
prochainement en revanche et c'est
là-dessus que je voudrais interroger
notamment la CPR ce qui a été voté pour
l'instant ne change rien aux entreprises
qui sont déjà présentes sur sur la place
et donc il y a ce niveau là vous l'avez
dit une soixantaine d'entreprises qui
sont simplement enregistrées est-ce que
l'on peut raisonnablement penser qu'elle
présente toutes des garanties en termes
de sécurité je crois que c'est une vraie
question et j'aimerais bien avoir votre
retour
et puis seconde question donc ça veut
dire dernière en bon français
monsieur Louvet indiqué qu'il y avait de
plus en plus de crypto actifs dans les
produits financiers on va dire
traditionnels je crois que ce serait
sans doute nécessaire que dans les
publicités sur ces produits cela
apparaissent très très clairement là
aussi dans un sécurité dans un souci de
d'information et de sécurisation des
épargnants
merci Hervé Vincent Segoin puis Eric
bouquet oui merci merci monsieur le
Président ma question va surtout vers
monsieur lever que j'ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'intérêt bien sûr comme tout
le monde d'ailleurs
je me fais surtout pas de mériter les
autres intervenants
mais vous parlez vous dites que la trade
des crypto monnaie se fait surtout sur
une part de patrimoine
en fonction du risque que les personnes
veulent prendre et la spéculation qui
peuvent engendrer
vous nous avez décrit un peu le type des
épargnants vous avez mais
j'ai cru entendre devant entendre ni
plus ni moins gestionnaire de patrimoine
puisque vous reprenez exactement les
mêmes principes que un gestionnaire de
patrimoine et vous vous allez faire de
la spéculation vers de la dynamique sur
avec la trade de la performance
ma question c'est et puis vous nous
dites aussi le principe majeur c'est
qu'il y a moins de régulation donc c'est
beaucoup plus simple
ma question c'est
vous dites qu'en même temps pour pour
continuer d'aller dans le sens de la
révolution qui est en train de se passer
sur les marchés il faut que y ait plus
de régulation alors première question
est-ce que c'est pas contradictoire
la seconde
vu que vous avez les mêmes propos qu'un
gestionnaire le patrimoine courant se en
quoi on vit une révolution réelle c'est
ma deuxième question et puis ma
troisième question va plutôt vers la CP1
et puis l'AMF
je crois que vous entendez comme tout le
monde que il y a moins de régulation
c'est plus facile c'est ce qui crée de
la trait alors certes beaucoup moins de
sécurité mais est-ce que du côté de la
CPAM de la MF faut-il revoir un peu
rationaliser un peu toutes les
protections qui ont été mises en place
pour
attirer un peu les épargnants vers vers
des systèmes plus que donc on connaît
tous et qui sont bien régulés
merci Vincent Eric Bocquet puis Michel
Cane et merci monsieur le Président
voilà vous dites que
est une société française de votre siège
social est à Paris je crois avenue de
l'opéra mais vous avez également été
enregistré au Luxembourg alors pourquoi
ce choix du Luxembourg
où est votre domicile et son fiscale en
fait c'est ma première question et j'ai
retrouvé un article des échos
entrepreneurs du 20 janvier 2022 qui est
à votre propos et qui disait
ouvre Luxembourg pour assurer
ses arrières et dans les développements
de l'article il y a deux aspects qui
sont évoqués l'aspect fiscal justement
puisqu'on nous explique au Luxembourg
les plus-values sur les ventes de crypto
monnaie sont exonérés au bout de six
mois de détention seulement j'imagine
qu'en France c'est différent
et l'article évoque également le début
de mise en place en France d'une
régulation du réglementation d'une
régulation sur le sujet et notamment
celle consistant à obtenir une
obligation d'obtenir un enregistrement
de prestataire de service sur les actifs
numériques ce qui j'imagine crée une
concurrence un peu
déséquilibré avec vos concurrents donc
étrangers comme base ou banance qui eux
ne seraient pas soumis à cette
réglementation là donc est-ce que le
choix du Luxembourg a été motivé comme
le dit l'article par ces deux raisons là
merci
merci monsieur le Président je remercie
aussi les différents intervenants pour
leurs explications alors on parle ici de
d'un taux de pénétration dans la
population
des crypto actifs qui est supérieur à
celui de l'actionnariat et on veut c'est
vrai soutenir
les activités des entreprises notamment
l'axe des entreprises dans une lecture
quelque chose d'assez significatif alors
on parle aussi de patrimoine de
placement etc donc il y a pour les
institutions traditionnelles d'un
certain nombre de
cartes de garde-fous de garantie qui
soit demandé notamment aux institutions
bancaires en termes de fonds propres
est-ce qu'il ne faut pas avoir aussi je
dirais un certain nombre un cadre
législatif beaucoup plus approprié
notamment tenant compte des données de
placement et de la nécessité de
mobiliser des fonds propres alors vous
avez cité totale dans le diaporama
l'exemple de FTX là et les dispositions
que vous avez prises pour rembourser les
clients mais est-ce que cela peut valoir
pour des enjeux financiers beaucoup plus
conséquent
merci je
vois pas d'autres questions si Monsieur
longuet
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse plutôt à Monsieur Louvet en
effet dans son document il distingue
les blockchain la preuve de travail et
celle qui preuve dangereux alors pour
être très honnête je n'y comprends rien
alors si vous fouillez me l'expliquer
serait formidable et brièvement
peut-être nous parler de l'économie de
l'activité de minage
de l'entreprise de minage
merci
Gérard je me tourne donc
elle nous inviter donc comme je l'ai
indiqué dans l'ordre des présentations
peut-être monsieur Perret voudra-t-il
répondre à tel ou tel des questions qui
ont été posées oui mais c'est le
président la première que j'ai retenu
c'était autour de la protection des
épargnants
donc comme je vous disais effectivement
dans le dispositif cette fois bancaire
classique le
la protection des épargnants elle passe
par plusieurs dispositifs d'abord la
protection du déposant avec le fond de
garantie des dépôts vous avez aussi donc
la garantie des épargnants notamment
avec le fond de garantie des titres si
jamais les titres qui étaient conservés
chez un intermédiaire disparaît c'est il
y a un dispositif de remboursement on a
rien de tout cela dans le domaine des
crypto actifs encore une fois ce sont
des crypto actifs ce ne sont pas des
crypto monnaie et si vous voulez pour la
protection des épargnants à ce stade
nous avons
une grosse préoccupation qui a été
résolue avec l'enregistrement renforcé
c'est déjà que les plateformes soient
robustes en termes d'attaque pour que
justement celui qui a un Wallet dans
lequel est déposé des crypto ne se
voient pas dérobés son actif mais dans
la protection des déposants en amont de
ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure de la
protection des des dépôts ou des actifs
vous avez le devoir de conseil qui
s'impose donc à tous les établissements
financiers qui aujourd'hui ne s'impose
pas au prestataires c'est un sujet qu'on
pourra réévoquer dans les questions qui
suivent il faut que celui qui est une
activité sur crypto actif soit éclairée
sur le risque qu'il prend du coup je
fais une une transition avec
l'intérêt sur ses actifs volatils quel
intérêt en les gens à vrai dire en tant
que en tant qu'autorité de supervision
nous sommes totalement agnostique sur
l'intérêt de cette chose là il faut
demander à l'investisseur quel est le
quel est le comment dirais-je la
dynamique psychologique qu'il soustend
son investissement à la fois le côté
spéculatif qu'il voit plutôt à la hausse
qu'à la baisse à la fois peut-être la
théorie de la surpondération des
probabilités faibles bien peut-être
expliquer ça sans son intérêt donc je
surpondais la chance de gagner c'est la
théorie aussi qu'on voit dans dans tout
ce qui est très au jeu quand bien même
je ne fais pas nécessairement un lien
direct entre les deux donc voilà si vous
voulez cet intérêt pour pour cette chose
là qui est comment dirais-je pas encadré
par la régulation en matière de devoir
de conseils de la part en tout cas le
devoir de conseil tel qu'entendu par la
réglementation c'est-à-dire où vous
faites une analyse de la de la de la
sensibilité de votre client et de sa
professionnalisation en matière
d'investissement évidemment c'est
quelqu'un qui a l'habitude d'investir
sur différents marchés ce n'est pas la
même chose le conseil que vous lui
donnez que celui qui
ignore tout et qui rentre dans le
domaine ça donc cette notion de conseil
je ne doute pas que que les promoteurs
des plateformes donnent des conseils
mais il n'est pas encadré avec si vous
voulez cette contrainte de bien analyser
le profil de son investisseur pour
adapter le Conseil voire refuser de lui
vendre un certain nombre de produits
sur les autres questions
risquées avantages donc l'avantage moi
je ne le je ne le qualifierai pas moi je
vais je vais caricaturer un peu le
propos je comprends que les crypto
actifs si vous voulez c'est comme un
système d'échange local c'est à dire
vous avez un certain nombre de personnes
qui s'accordent à reconnaître une valeur
à un élément et qu'il s'en servent comme
mener des changes d'une certaine manière
si je prends un exemple deux exemples un
sérieux à moins sérieux quand Facebook a
créé libre appui diem
son objectif semblait bien être d'avoir
un stable coin c'est à dire un Diem
contre un euro ou un panier de monnaie
donc avec une valeur si vous voulez
stable avec une contrepartie Fiat il
avait pour vocation de mettre en
circulation dans sa communauté de 2
milliards et demi de facebooker si vous
me permettez l'expression quelque chose
qu'il permettait de faire des
transactions des achats et des ventes en
s'affranchissant de Visa MasterCard de
telle sorte à pouvoir capter les
commissions de paiement et c'est dans
cet environnement Facebook que ce
symbole avait une vraie valeur vous
allez pas prendre le Diem et aller
acheter votre baguette à la boulangerie
illustration moins sérieuse pour ceux
qui connaissaient le système du club
Méditerrané autrefois vous échangez vos
euros comptez vous autour de votre
collier et ça avait une valeur dans
cette espèce de système d'échange local
et de voilà donc moi j'ai pas de j'ai
pas de de propos de superviseur quant à
l'avantage de cet élément en revanche et
vous l'avez compris j'ai plutôt un une
approche sur le risque donc le risque
détournement de dévoiement de ce système
notamment pour le pour le financement de
terrorisme
vous disiez que aujourd'hui en effet il
y a un stock donc par rapport à
l'enregistrement renforcé rien ne change
sur la situation des PSN aujourd'hui
enregistrés donc 62 Marianne je crois
c'est ce que tu as dit
et est-ce qu'on est à
comment dirais-je au benchmark ou aux
parents Gon en termes de sécurité
deux réponses à cela dans le contrôle
sur pièce que nous faisons
on procède mais ces déclaratifs à un
certain nombre d'enquêtes avec donc des
questionnaires qui nous permettent
d'identifier des acteurs qui sont plus
ou moins risqués qui font partie
d'ailleurs des ingrédients qui nous
permettent de faire notre programme
d'inspection mais pas que
et ensuite nous ont des contrôles sur
place alors écoutez à l'expérience
je ne peux pas préjugé du fait que le
marché soit tout à fait en tout cas les
acteurs soient tout à fait un niveau
parce que fort de nos contrôles en
pourcentage de ceux qui ont été radiés
parce qu'une appliquait pas des
dispositifs ils apparaît important nous
avons commencé donc ces inspections
l'année dernière nous allons avoir un
nombre d'inspections beaucoup plus dense
cette année donc je pourrais avoir un
recul un peu plus important quand à la
situation de ces prestataires pour
savoir s'ils sont à niveau nous partons
du principe que en les ai enregistré et
analyseur dispositif en tout cas ils
avaient une intention de l'être ensuite
il faut s'assurer comme je le disais
tout à l'heure que c'est effectif et
qu'on passe du PowerPoint à la mise en
place effective donc là j'aurais un peu
plus de recul au fur et à mesure que
nous étendons notre champ de contrôle
pour avoir une assurance et vous
répondre fermement donc comme je le
disais tout à l'heure la bonne phase
présume mais le la confiance n'excit pas
le contrôle donc nous irons sur place
pour pour nous en assurer et pouvoir et
pouvoir
donc il répondent sur les cryptos qui
font partie d'un d'un actif ou d'un
portefeuille enfin ou d'un produit
financier
donc qui qui
revient à ce que j'ai tout à l'heure sur
le devoir de conseil si c'est un
intermédiaire bancaire au assimilé qui
vous vend un produit
je sais pas si un produit d'assurance
vie propose en plus de des ucés des ucés
ou des comportements crypto en tout cas
si si la question tourne autour d'un
produit financier packagé avec du crypto
si c'est un banquier ou un autre
investissement qui le vend il a un
devoir de conseil il a un devoir de
catégoriser son client savoir si il est
suffisamment aguerri au risque
financiers pour lui dire vous pouvez
parce que normalement si il considère
que c'est pas le cas il ne doit pas lui
vendre le produit
alors après et je finirai là-dessus
avant de passer la parole à Marianne sur
sur ces sujets comment faire quand on a
un dispositif qui est moins régulier qui
est plus facile pour avoir plus de
sécurité pour attirer les épargnants
peut-être je reproduire un biais en
reproduisant un système existant
c'est-à-dire celui qui aurait été
embarqué par l'agrement l'agrément et
qui applique plus de contraintes à ces
acteurs mais qui ont une vocation à
sécuriser les opérations et la
protection de des particuliers ou des
investisseurs dans ce domaine
et bien c'est la ségrégation des actifs
c'est la la surveillance des flux et
aussi de la liquidité effective de ces
de ces prestataires pour faire face aux
demandes de retrait et donc être en
mesure de remplir ces obligations donc
c'est un peu plus de régulation vous
dire que il faut pas imaginer
la population un peu plus adaptée à au
secteur probablement ça fera partie des
discussions qu'on aura avec les acteurs
nous avons besoin de bien comprendre les
opérations pour bien calibrer la
régulation mais on retrouve des grands
principes quand même qui ont été
d'ailleurs appelés au moment de la
faillite de FTX c'est de bien séparer
les actifs des des
investisseurs de des activités propres
de l'entreprise je vous rappelle qu'il y
a eu quelques années un progrès
important fait dans dans le domaine de
la protection des titres on a mis en
place des règles pour éviter de tirer
sur la masse c'est à dire qu'un
intermédiaire utilisait les titres de
ses clients pour faire ses propres
opérations pour ton propre donc c'est
ces espèces de de comment dirais-je
mauvaise mauvais comportement qui sont
susceptibles d'apparaître quand on n'a
pas des règles imposant cette
ségrégation sont donc un sujet très
important je rappelle que seuls les
banques parce qu'elles sont régulées à
tous les niveaux
superviser par la CPR ont le droit parce
que c'est la réaction de transformation
d'utiliser des dépôts de leurs clients
pour financer par exemple les crédits
immobiliers mais parce qu'elles se sont
des institutions qui sont d'abord très
surveillées qui ont des tas de règles de
gestion etc pour des activités type
crypto ou type autrefois de la planète
des maisons titre mais de cette nature
on a bien on doit bien avoir des règles
de ségrégation des avoir pour assurer la
sécurité et le cas échéant accroître si
vous voulez le confort des investisseurs
dans ce domaine sachant que quand on est
sur un crypto actif pur type Bitcoin et
autres on est surnément extrêmement
volatiles parce qu'il y a pas de
contrepartie on est bien sur quelque
chose qui est issu du travail d'un
processeur avec quelques électrons et en
quelque sorte on vous donne une médaille
parce que vous avez réussi à résoudre
une équation en revanche quand vous êtes
sur des crypto actifs qui sont donc
ont des contreparties donc en actif
sous-jacent
au pcvm ou des monnaies ou d'acheter
contre contre monnaie là on a on a une
base qui est qui est très différente et
donc ça donne pas lieu à la même chose
et je disais que je finirai là-dessus
mais je vais finir sur un dernier point
parce que ça a été évoqué je crois par
Monsieur Louvet
comme des banques
acquièrent des crypto à leur bilan le
comité de balle a décidé de traiter ces
crypto en termes de charges en fonds
propres à mettre en face de ces crypto
pour couvrir un risque inattendu
de deux manières principales donc je
simplifie si la banque détient un
crypto à 7 qui est fondée sur une
monnaie il va pondérer le risque qu'il a
par rapport à ce crypto à 7 au regard de
la valeur de cette monnaie donc en
principe c'est du cash il n'aura 0 à
mettre en fond propre en face sauf un
petit chouïa au titre du risque
opérationnel qu'il a d'être en contact
avec une plateforme qui est susceptible
de faire défaut comme n'importe quelle
institution en revanche si jepim Morgan
BNP c'était général achète un Bitcoin
nous lui dirons c'est une non valeur où
les déduisez intégralement de vos fonds
propres non seulement vous mettez pas de
son propre en face mais vous déduisez la
tot de vos valeurs alors je vous
rappelle que quand ils font un prêt une
entreprise etc ils pondèrent leur risque
en fonction du risque et ils mettent
toujours en face un élément de fonds
propres donc voilà comment le
superviseur voit le sujet donc le
superviseur de manière agnostique sur
son existence en regard de ses risques
c'est la lcbft et c'est si c'est une
institution financière pour pas que par
contagion elle met en danger les
déposants on considère que ce qu'elle a
à son actif est à valeur nulle et
qu'elle doit totalement déduire de ses
fonds propres ou que c'est un crypto
actif qui a un sous-jacent qui a une
valeur ok le cas c'est un principe de
transparence qui sera appliqué voilà
j'ai peut-être été un peu long mais je
remercie de votre attention
merci Monsieur Perrin en tout cas
c'était
sur la dernière partie sur laquelle vous
avez souhaité porter l'attention c'était
très clair
monsieur Louvet pour les questions qui
vous revenez
merci alors je vais commencer par pas
forcément dans le dans le bon orne et
peut-être d'avoir répondre à celle du
sénateur
Boké donc c'est bien une société
française on est basé comme vous l'avez
dit siège social est à Paris
domiciliation fiscale à Paris comme ma
propre domicile
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a voulu créer une
une activité au Luxembourg parce que le
Luxembourg en fait a été comme d'autres
pays européens l'un de ceux à dire que
si vous souhaitez faire une activité
dans leur pays il faut avoir
une un enregistrement dans dans cette
dans cet état c'est le cas d'un certain
nombre de de pays
et ça ne vous aura pas échappé qu'au
Luxembourg il y a une base assez
intéressante en matière de gestion
d'actifs c'est un pays qui
qui est dynamique de ce point de vue là
c'est un pays dans lequel il y a aussi
pas mal de banques privées
et c'est un pays dans lequel il y a une
clientèle qui qui peut s'apparenter à la
clientèle
haut de gamme qui composent une partie
de notre nos effectifs on a eu pas mal
de contacts sur place avec des
intermédiaires
et certains gestionnaires d'actifs et on
a aussi remarqué que en matière de
gestion de fond il y a une activité dont
on parle pas beaucoup c'est la
conservation de crypto au titre de des
activités de
de conservation équivalente à celle des
conservateurs de titres donc quand vous
avez un fond d'investissement vous devez
conserver les titres et faire appel à
une société spécialisée pour pour cela
dans l'univers crypto dès lors que vous
avez des fonds d'investissement qui
veulent détenir des jetons dans ce cas
là ils ont pas le droit de les conserver
eux-mêmes il faut qu'il passe par une la
société spécialisée or il y a très peu
de sociétés spécialisées nous on a une
filiale également française qui est
belle quand il est ce que je te dis ça
ici ce qui est également enregistré
auprès de l'AMF mais également
enregistré auprès de la CSSF dont
l'activité c'est juste de la
conservation et donc l'idée derrière le
l'installation de l'enregistrement et la
création d'une petite entité locale au
Luxembourg c'est de pouvoir essayer de
capter ce marché luxembourgeois de la
gestion d'actifs et notamment de la
conservation de titres crypto dans des
fonds d'investissement et on a déjà
quelques clients dans ce domaine et par
ailleurs d'aller démarcher des sociétés
d'assurance vie ou d'autres prestataires
avec lequel on pourrait faire un
partenariat parce que eux ne sont pas
enregistrés n'ont pas forcément vocation
à l'être nous on dispose de la
technologie et du savoir faire et donc
on peut créer des opérations gagnants
gagnants pour aller conquérir des
marchés des marchés des marchés nouveaux
et c'est exactement dans cette démarche
par ailleurs il se trouve que le fond
souverain du Luxembourg
nous a fait confiance et à investi aussi
dans l'entreprise à travers le ministère
des Finances du Luxembourg ce qui est
pas une mauvaise une mauvaise chose et
donc ça renvoie de de la balle que j'ai
trouvé plutôt plutôt pertinent je
reviens du coup à la à l'une des
questions sur la gestion de patrimoine
et notamment les produits financiers
crypto je suis sans doute mal exprimé et
je vous prie de m'excuser aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de produits financiers
d'assurance vie qui inclut de la crypto
en revanche c'est une volonté et c'est
quelque chose que j'aimerais pousser et
c'est quelque chose que j'estime être
pertinent bien évidemment
la ce type de gestion doit remplir les
règles de gestion applica ces produits
donc dès lors qu'il y a de la crypto
dans un produit financier traditionnel
le client l'investisseur doit donc être
va informer et il doit bénéficier des
mêmes conseils sur ces sur ces produits
on pense et ma vision c'est que
ces actifs font pour partie
d'entre eux pas tous il y a énormément
de crypto actifs il y en a beaucoup qui
ont présente un intérêt extrêmement
mineur voire absolument nul mais pour un
certain nombre d'actifs il y a un
intérêt à les introduire dans
l'industrie financière dans les produits
de financés traditionnelle c'est un
souhait c'est quelque chose sur lequel
on a envie de travailler c'est avec des
sujets qu'on ouvre avec un certain
nombre d'acteurs et c'est dans ce cadre
là que
je m'exprimais et que je pense qu'il est
pertinent de d'agir nous à ce stade on
ne vend quand on vend des produits par
exemple les produits de gestion pilotés
c'est du 100% crypto qui sont vendus
avec sans même d'ailleurs que
l'enregistrement ne nous oblige à le
faire avec les type d'exigence que celle
de l'agrément ou la vente de produits
financiers traditionnels c'est-à-dire un
questionnaire une évaluation du
patrimoine et de l'appétit au risque du
client un système de limites chez nous
qui en place depuis 2017 qui consiste à
vous demander préalablement à vos
investissements quel est votre
patrimoine et la preuve de votre
patrimoine votre bulletin de saveur vos
avis d'imposition un certain nombre
d'éléments qui nous permet de calculer
ensuite un score associé au client pour
lui dire compte tenu de sa richesse il
peut investir tel montant un jeune qui
s'inscrit sur la plateforme et qui se
déclare comme étant ne possédant pas
d'appartement étant locataire ou vivant
chez ses parents n'ayant pas de revenus
fixes étant
n'ayant pas de patrimoine enfin ayant
répondu à toutes les questions qu'on lui
pose on va pas l'autoriser à investir 30
000 euros dans les crypto même si ça
vient de son BNP Paribas dont on
pourrait juger que la banque a fait ses
prérogatives non il sera limité à 3000
euros par an et s'il veut faire plus bah
il va devoir justifier on a classé des
populations si il y a certaines
catégories de
socioprofessionnels qui pour nous ne
permettent pas d'investir le maximum
qu'on autorise dès lors que vous nous
avez fourni un justificatif comme un
avis d'imposition et que vous faites des
opérations argument bancaires
rappelez-vous l'argent vient mais chez
coynehouse de banque puisqu'il est nos
clients sont des clients français
essentiellement ou européens ils font
des virements depuis la Société Générale
la BNP le Crédit Lyonnais sur notre
compte bancaire à la Société Générale
pour investir chez nous l'argent il
vient d'un système économique ça vient
pas d'un c'est pas du cash ou ou il y a
une certaine il y a tout un modèle de
scoring qu'on a développé qui permet
d'analyser ça merci Monsieur Ferret je
suis obligé de suivre désolé je parle
trop il y avait d'autres questions sur
le prof of War qui profite manuel vallon
qui est directeur
scientifique et qui est un grand expert
du sujet en le plaisir de vous expliquer
la différence et l'économie du minage et
ça on pourra le faire peut-être après ou
séparément si vous le souhaitez merci
beaucoup madame fleuret les points qui
n'ont pas encore été abordés ce qui
mériterait une réponse de votre part
merci pour vos questions effectivement
il y a plusieurs plusieurs points je
vais essayer d'être efficace il y a une
question sur l'engouement autour des des
actifs numériques et l'acquisition à
hauteur de 8% des Français aujourd'hui
et probablement plus demain dans cette
étude que nous avons mené on a pu aussi
sonder sur les raisons derrière cette
investissement donc effectivement on a
bien sûr la recherche de rendement et
c'est intéressant de noter que c'est
aussi pour des vocations de placement à
long terme mais pas
exclusivement de la spéculation à court
terme il y a également tous les nouveaux
usages derrière les crypto actifs qui ne
sont pas associés aux associés aux
paiement ou à l'investissement
on a et de façon très intéressante
beaucoup de Français qui aussi
souhaitent tester un nouveau système
dans lequel ils ont le sentiment que
leur vie privée et leur donner
personnelles sont aussi mieux préservés
et mieux protégés d'où ces
expérimentations là et enfin parmi les
raisons évoquées la possibilité
également d'expérimenter des nouveaux
moyens de paiement et c'est pour ça que
c'est assez important de revenir sur ce
point puisqu'on a le développement et
cela a été évoqué puisqu'on a beaucoup
entendu parler de Diem de Facebook qui
est un des nouveaux jeux ton stables qui
peut servir comme moyen de paiement et
très intéressant de noter qu'aujourd'hui
ce sont effectivement ces jetons stables
qui qui sont le pilier fondateur d'un
certain nombre d'applications développés
sur les sur les réseaux blockchain et
que malheureusement à ce stade la
plupart de ces jeux sont stables ou
stable coin si vous en avez entendu
parler sont des stibbull coin dollars
pour 99% en réalité de l'ensemble des
style coin donc on manque cruellement de
stable coin euro et malheureusement donc
le public français européen à
disposition davantage de ces peu neuro
et on est en train de reproduire
l'hégémonies du dollar dans cette
nouvelle économie numérique ce qui pour
pour notre souveraineté représente une
menace sévère et c'est pourquoi nous
prenons le développement par des acteurs
européens de ces nouveaux actifs puisque
si nous le faisons pas ce que nous
voyons c'est que des acteurs américains
le font à notre place puisque les deux
plus gros émetteurs de dollars
numériques appelons comme ça sont aussi
choisi des maîtres de l'euro numérique
ce qui est une pause effectivement des
questionnants du point de vue de la
souveraineté il y avait des questions
sur la consommation d'énergie
effectivement le minage est consommateur
d'énergie le ménage représente une des
façons dont les réseaux blockchain
peuvent fonctionner mais pas l'unique
donc on a aussi des protocoles qui ne
nécessitent pas la consommation
d'énergie et donc cette problématique de
consommation d'énergie va principalement
se concentrer sur le réseau sur le
réseau Bitcoin de réseau blockchain
Bitcoin ce qui est intéressant aussi de
noter et en particulier dans le contexte
actuel c'est qu'aujourd'hui les mineurs
qui sont donc derrière cette cette
économie vont davantage avoir recours
de l'énergie renouvelable
par rapport
à leur business model où ils ont besoin
d'une énergie et qui effectivement la
moins chère et qu'en réalité aujourd'hui
les mineurs de par l'utilisation de ce
surplus d'énergie renouvelable
deviennent les clients en dernier
ressort pour autant rentabiliser des
lieux de production où cette énergie est
aujourd'hui invendue ou gaspiller donc
on a une opportunité par le
développement de cette nouvelle de cette
nouvelle branche de l'économie de
l'énergie en réalité d'aller même
subventionner le développement de ces
énergies ne renouvelables et c'est
malheureusement un pan beaucoup moins
connu de cette innovation
il y a eu plusieurs questions sur la
réglementation
nous avons un sujet en marge de
réglementation sur la supervision que
j'ai pu évoquer rapidement mais qui se
pose aujourd'hui en France et se posera
d'autant plus avec l'harmonisation à
l'Europe de la réglementation nous avons
déjà aujourd'hui des atteintes aux
conditions de concurrence loyale
en France et nous craignons d'avoir ces
mêmes menaces au niveau européen
notamment puisqu'il sera possible avec
la mise en place de la réglementation
européenne pour des acteurs étrangers de
s'adresser au public européen sans être
encadré par nos règles du moment où ils
affirment ne pas faire une communication
proactive ne pas s'adresser directement
au public avec les abus que l'on connaît
de cette notion et les difficultés de
supervision derrière d'aller chercher
des acteurs qui ne sont pas établis en
Europe et qui vont néanmoins s'adresser
à notre public donc c'est qu'une menace
vraiment très sérieuse qui qui pèse
aussi sur la compétitivité et le
développement de notre de nos
entreprises et s'il faut répéter qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui déjà les plus les plus
sûr et sérieuses et qui le seront demain
en respect de la réglementation il y
avait une question sur les fonds propres
également du point de la réglementation
les exigences en matière de fonds
propres pour les acteurs sont parts du
règlement Mika qui va être qui mettre en
application en 2024 donc c'est une
question qui a été traitée concernant
l'ajout concernant les récents débats
lors du projet de loi d'adultes et le
renforcement de la réglementation des
scènes effectivement il nous semble une
approche beaucoup plus pragmatique de
partir sur un enregistrement renforcé
pardon plutôt qu'un agrément par rapport
aux obstacles qu'il existe aujourd'hui
pour obtenir l'agrément il faut noter
qu'il y a des acteurs qui ont déjà tenté
d'obtenir cet agrément qui sont
enregistrés donc tenté d'aller à la
marche la marche d'après c'est
d'ailleurs quelque chose que nous
prenons à l'association puisque c'est
celle qui cette agrément effectivement
se rapprochait des exigences qui vont
être demandées au niveau européen la
réalité c'est qu'il y a des obstacles à
l'obtention de cet agrément donne des
conditions qui sont en pratique très
difficile voire impossible de respecter
la question de l'assurance RC
responsabilité civile professionnelle
que les acteurs doivent obtenir en
études et c'est une bonne nouvelle
puisque le calendrier de ce pendule là
n'a pas été accélé puisque nous avons
d'abord à résoudre la problématique
auprès des assurances puisque
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas un produit qui
est proposé aux psan en revanche et
c'est là où nous sommes beaucoup plus
inquiets les exigences en matière de
cybersécurité sont également un des
volets les plus difficiles et surtout
les plus coûteux pour notamment les
nouveaux acteurs à respecter et
effectivement c'est enfin c'est pour ça
que ça nous inquiète beaucoup que ces
exigences aient été ajoutées dans
leurrement renforcé même si je rejoins
tout ça fait ce qui a été dit il y a
évidemment un besoin pour la protection
d'investisseurs d'avoir des garanties
fournies par Epson de de la résilience
de leur système informatique néanmoins
il y a d'abord un enjeu de résoudre ces
problématiques qui sont nécessaires bien
sûr par rapport à cet enregistrement
renforcé du coup mais aussi du point de
vue de la réglementation européenne et
c'est ce sont des problématiques qui se
posent aux acteurs qui ont besoin de
clarification qui ont besoin de
recrutement mais aussi au niveau des
autorités par rapport à l'autorisation
et la supervision de ce volet très
spécifique voilà je sais pas si j'ai
plus de temps mais sinon s'il y avait
sur les autres questions que vous avez
pas eu de réponse vous souhaitez des
précisions bien sûr nous sommes
disponibles à l'issue de cette audition
pour pour revenir plus largement merci
beaucoup merci Madame Fleury je donne la
parole maintenant pour quelques mots de
conclusion à Marianne Baba Layani de
comprendre qu'il faut être bref donc je
vais donner peut-être trois précisions
techniques et un mode conclusion sur les
précisions techniques d'abord plusieurs
questions liées à la protection des
épargnants et aux liens entre les
produits financiers traditionnels ou les
acteurs financiers traditionnels et les
crypto donc peut-être une précision
effectivement je crois que ça avait été
dit d'ailleurs par la dent les crypto ne
peuvent pas être dans des OPCVM
aujourd'hui ils peuvent être dans des
fonds
destinés aux professionnels mais à
hauteur de 10% seulement donc il y a un
certain nombre de protections qui ont
été mises en place pour limiter ou
éviter en tout cas le
comment dire la fuite du monde crypto
vers le monde financier traditionnel
ceci tant que le monde crypto n'est pas
passé dans un mode de régulation qui
faut-il le rappeler va être le cas en
Europe et pour l'instant on n'est pas
non plus dans un univers totalement
harmonisé au niveau mondial même si il y
a d'autres juridictions d'ailleurs
qui ont mis en place des réglementations
sur les crypto c'est le cas notamment du
Japon et je crois que les États-Unis s'y
acheminent la vitesse grand V après les
événements liés à FTX donc premier
élément technique deuxièmement sur la
consommation d'énergie effectivement il
y a dans le règlement européen Mika
nobligation d'informer les épargnants
sur la consommation des mécanismes de
minage donc ce n'est pas un mécanisme
comment dire de plafonnement ou quoi que
ce soit mais c'est quand même un
mécanisme d'information des épargnants
et donc on fait aussi là aussi confiance
aux épargnants sur l'idée qu'ils vont se
pencher sur cette question et en tenir
compte nous constatons par ailleurs à
l'AMF ça serait un tout autre sujet mais
effectivement que la finance durable est
quand même une demande croissante des
épargnants et donc je ne doute pas que
s'il venait à constater qu'ils sont
confrontés à des dispositifs qui sont
très préjudiciables à l'environnement
ils ont tiraient un certain nombre de
conséquences en fonction de leur
préférence évidemment enfin sur les
les obligations
d'information des clients alors en effet
il faut être clair le dispositif
d'enregistrement simple ne prévoit aucun
mécanisme de protection des épargnants
je crois que je l'ai déjà dit
il s'appliquent néanmoins mais c'est
très général les dispositions générales
sur le fait que la communication
professionnelle doit être précise et
loyale et ne doit pas constituer une
pratique commerciale trompeuse mais ça
ce sont les dispositions générales du
Code de la Consommation et on voit bien
qu'elles ont les plus difficiles d'en
trouver l'application
dans un domaine qui est proche du
secteur financier c'est pourquoi le
dispositif d'abord d'enregistrement
renforcé puis d'agrément va inclure un
certain nombre d'éléments qui vont
contribuer à la protection des
épargnants entretien à le redire et ça
sera ma conclusion c'est effectivement
un plaidoyer pour ce type de de
régulation qui va bien au-delà de
l'enregistrement puisqu'on aura à la
fois des obligations matières de gestion
des conflits d'intérêts des obligations
sur le contrôle interne des obligations
sur la mise en place de procédures de
traitement des réclamations donc on voit
qu'on commence à se rapprocher quand
même d'un univers de protection des
épargnants qui certes n'est pas
équivalent et ça a été mentionné il y a
pas de fonds de garantie il y a pas de
d'obligation de conseils aussi précise
que dans le domaine financier entre
guillemets classiques mais on a un
certain nombre de garde-fous qui sont
mis en place également aussi lorsqu'il y
a un service de conservation une
obligation de ségrégation des actifs
numériques donc en un mot commençant
c'est pour cela que comme la CPR
d'ailleurs nous avons été favorables à
aller le plus rapidement possible vers
le dispositif d'agrément qu'il faut-il
le rappeler et le seul qui existe dans
le règlement européen c'est à dire que
de toute façon à un moment donné il
faudra effectivement qu'on se mette
collectivement avec avec les acteurs du
secteur et on y travaille évidemment en
situation de passer dans un régime
d'agrément qui devrait
donner un certain nombre d'assurance
mais encore une fois il faut être clair
ce ne sont pas exactement les le même ce
ne sera pas exactement le même niveau de
protection des épargnants que ce qui
existe sur un certain nombre de produits
financiers traditionnels ça veut dire et
ça sera ma conclusion qu'il faut
continuer effectivement à être clair
dans le la communication qui est faite
vis-à-vis des épargnants sur les risques
sur la volatilité des actifs ce ne sont
pas d'ailleurs les seules actifs
financiers qui sont volatiles il faut
être clair on a parlé tout à l'heure de
la comparaison avec la détention
d'action bon c'est vrai que les actions
c'est aussi un actif financier risqué
ça ça veut dire qu'il faut effectivement
plaider c'est tout l'enjeu de
l'éducation financière je conclurai par
là sur la diversification sur le fait
que on ne met pas tout son argent dans
des produits risqués etc ça je pense
qu'il y a un accord un accord assez
général autour de cette notion qui est
que en effet ce sont des actifs qui
comportent des risques importants qui ne
bénéficient pas des mêmes protections
que les actifs financiers traditionnels
et donc il n'est pas interdit aux
épargnants ça n'est pas le choix qui a
été fait de d'investir dans ce type
d'actif mais il faut qu'il le fasse en
connaissance de cause en étant conscient
de leur risque merci beaucoup
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
la président de la dame c'est
monsieur Louvet également et Monsieur le
Secrétaire final merci beaucoup merci de
cette audition très utile en tout cas
pour nous tous bonne journée à tous